B was the same guy that was like yo, can you close deals in December? I'm like dude, come on
Yeah, you can and I literally that's why I put that on my story
I said do bear do bear shit in the wood
There's a bear shit in the woods and you said not in December, which I know we were both joking
But guys it is December like that's a really good. In fact, I want to bring that up
Some of you guys are frustrated. Like I had a couple people that were like, hey
I've got these campaigns that are not like there's no clicks
Impressions and all this different shit, but there's no clicks and I a couple of those people I said, okay
What are your niches and a lot of them are niches that we said were good like concrete tree service
They are good, but you guys have to still keep in mind. There's other factors, right?
so for example, if you are thinking you're gonna do like a concrete Legion in South Dakota or North Dakota or
Minnesota and it's gonna pop off in December
It's not okay, you're still probably gonna get a lead here and there but guys it's cold as shit than those places
People don't want it like I have tree service clients that literally don't work in the winter
So if I was doing tree service, I would think what spots are warm
Florida feet like there's just one more layer. I shouldn't have to cover that you guys need to just use your head, right?
It's the same thing. Don't go put up an artificial grass site in some shitty-ass city in Kansas
Because it year-round it's probably not gonna be that great go do it in the Florida and the Phoenix and the Vegas whatever, right?
and obviously take it through module one, but the reason that B has been so successful is
He the niche he's going after and now everyone's gonna be like, oh towing is the niche
The reason that's good is because he's hitting it while it's hot. That's great
You hit it while it's hot slap him in a contract now. He's gonna when he pitches the deal
He needs to make sure to say hey, look, we know December's hot
But when it gets a little bit slower in the summer whenever the slow season is for for towing
It's the same thing as the winter for concrete. So B's getting leads quick because he's in towing is it because it's towing
No, it's because he's picking a niche now like I'm just throwing that out there because I know a couple of you guys
You guys still have to be humans, okay, you still have to consider that I am NOT doing concrete in Minnesota
No way in hell. Okay, so start using our heads a little bit
I'm also not doing snow removal just because it's hot right now because it's gonna be completely dead in the summer. Okay